Boris Johnson's first big speech since
leaving the EU I wouldn't even mention
the name of the controversy except to
say that it begins with beings receding
in the past behind us brexit it's still
not over
whatever the PM says the future trade
deals not even begun the PM trying to
dial down the drama let's be clear the
choice is emphatically not Deal or No
Deal we have a deal the question is
whether we agree a trading relationship
with the EU comparable to Canada's or
more like Australia's but what does that
mean Canada has a trade deal with the EU
Australia doesn't so we're back to Deal
or No Deal
after all you said in the election that
there was absolutely zero chance that
the UK would leave the EU with no deal
now you seem to be talking up no deal as
an Australian style arrangement we have
a deal what I said during the election
you'll have you say me to be able deal
it's a great deal and it was having
ready and it's gone through that is a
new euphemism for no deal isn't it
because there is no trade agreement you
can point to as I said to to Beth we
have a deal and we're coming out we have
come out on the basis of that the deal
that you did was a divorce deal you do
not yet have a long-term deal right of
all the people I said earlier on we've
got a deal it's a great deal but we're
out mr. Johnson's cheerleaders happy to
toe the line there's no doubt in my mind
that for both the EU and for the UK is
going to be in our interest that we get
a good deal but just one thing it is
fair to say that Australia style deal is
is no deal I mean Australia negotiate an
FTA with the EU at the moment well no as
the prime minister said we have a deal
Donald Trump's Malan lied I'm more
interested in a deal with the u.s. I am
optimistic I think you know the prime
ministers of schedule is by the end of
the year and I think that's totally
doable what should he prioritize the EU
or the US or that's up to the prime
minister the Labour leader says no deal
still a risk and time is short he has
not published what his negotiating
object--
is between now and the end of the year
when he's got to reach an agreement with
the European Union the European Union
will no doubt be very strong on
maintaining alignment on regulations he
has got to come up with an answer
this the moment we left the EU but the
clock ticking now on a new deadline 11
months to secure a trade deal with
Europe or face another brexit cliff edge
Beth Rigby Sky News Westminster